i come from holland from amsterdam and
before that country was invaded and the
blissfully
happy family days that we had but they
sort of sadden you in a way because
how different it all would have been you
know if
if hitler had never come to power
stephen frank was a child when he his
mother and two brothers were imprisoned
at the rajan start concentration camp
because
of their religion it was the last
stopping point for those who to be taken
to the death camps of eastern europe
when you're a child
and that's why after all i was only nine
years old
you don't so to think very much about
the the future
are we going to be passed on to
auschwitz you almost sort of accept well
that is how it is and it's really
the the adults who are the ones of
course who um
who um took the strain i i always say i
sort of compare it with you know my
my parents generation they swam in a sea
of blood
we just floated in it and some of us
were fortunate enough
to come ashore stephen says he
owes his life to his mother who kept her
sons secretly washed and
fed for survivors like him the holocaust
is a story of limitless loss
they are witnesses to the most monstrous
crime in history
the nazis wiped more than six million
jews
and millions of others off the face of
the earth
76 years on since the liberation that
brought it to an end
the chief rabbi says this warning from
history is being unheeded
we haven't learned the lessons and so we
have seen various genocides taking place
in bosnia cambodia darfur rwanda
we're seeing the rohingya today we're
seeing the uyghurs today
suffering being persecuted in a horrific
manner
the unimaginable horrors of the 1994
rwandan genocide hold frightening
similarities to the plight of european
jews
marie was just a teenager at the time of
the massacre which took the lives of a
million people
including much of her family it's a
matter of saying
i would rather die instead of continue
leaving and watching what i was watching
so that's where i was so as a matter of
thinking i might as well die like
everyone else
so there was no hope of future there was
no hope of anything
this year holocaust memorial day is
going beyond just remembering the terror
of world war
ii but victims of all genocides
commemorating those murdered
for who they were candles will be lit at
eight o'clock tonight
following a virtual ceremony to serve as
a reminder
that through hatred humanity can be the
light to overcome darkness
ashna harinag sky news